guys is my first time Nelson okay all
right now got ot all right guys
it's my first time log in with my new
camera that I got for Christmas I'm
going to start vlogging in the cabin and
we take over this place
or like take over vlogging maybe for you
moving how's your sleep
me too it was hard for me okay see ya
how are you I'm doing good I'm ready for
this road trip are you ready yeah yeah
yeah you're holding it like this - it's
such a small camera okay are you ready
for it Arkansas yeah you're funny
the cameras shaking - tornado Oh the
tornado I feel dizzy can't zoom in she
is ready and my day has been good so far
of the first day vlogging
in the beginning part it's now going to
end right now it's just the beginning
yeah it's been a really good beginning
of the day what's that gonna do you know
we have to [ __ ] sighs its sneer here
just me here you know it's near what's
the place where New Orleans oh I never
knew what Arkansas was until like now
Arkin says that's hot stuff let's take a
look at the mad [ __ ] sass yes
Louisiana is right below Arkansas you
are geographically correct I see I
looked at the map yesterday you know
iPad he noticed that no those yesterday
hey saucer kept a saucer up hey I was
gonna help you do it again cutie pie
Maureen carry for you how are you good
how smuggling goods you like it yeah I
started flying like today yeah but you
know what you'd block the thing is you
still have edited quesadilla edit it all
cases okay see Casey's gonna edit it
morning mr. Channing
how are you ready yep Martinson you
Norma Jackie's mother
okay are you going to do a British
accent
right now I'm very bad at doing it very
very bad yeah where's my pop puck oh
thank you very much mother
mmm sorry guys now we are going on the
car and if you want to know what how it
looks this is the gigantic car that
inside I think it serves the seats are
comfy I don't know it may be a different
one but I really love this van none of
it is this cool
comfy it's just sleeping and like hang
out all right we're in the vein right
now and we're watching a movie cuz we
just noticed the van has a movie player
DVD player accent or watching grease
whatever that movie is see a word at the
cabin maybe on my blog a little more
[Music]
all right we are in Argos all right now
and we're outside of the cabin and
husband at mr. chan good yeah just for
the vlog it's for you guys better watch
danger stairs may be slippery use handle
we're about you Wow that's close hey
this is good nice oh so good
you're like in the woods would vlogging
yeah cool there's a lake this is
beautiful guys these is very beautiful
see if he can find any animals slip
right there
this place is a creepy place to get lost
in especially at dark now there is a
reason for me to be scared when I'm
sleeping other eyes and moves and maybe
I know it's covered and it's fun a
pathway right now and these two right
here where you can see of you everywhere
you
[Music]
so quiet room ibadah check out the cabin
I'm so excited and you guys should be
excited too if you wanted all right
let's do this
all right guys we are now in the cabin
and as we saw in the pictures this is my
bunk bed
do you want to sleep in here you want to
have a sleepover yeah you want to sleep
over which one you want to talk about
top row address
it's right here it's built into it
yeah yeah we also get a distance between
these are stairs don't eat little stairs
so children and children Joe and here's
outside as we saw earlier all right this
is okay I'm a little family
[Music]
look who's up here okay and I was lost
for a second alright guys this is the
pride of the house the kitchen there's
the door
that's all I give you is all I can show
you right now
[Music]
[Music]